a company announced they were selling
fantasy startup investing nfts and they
launched a beta for this and then shut
it down 24 hours later the startup is
called vision rare
and it was co-founded by a former french
vc associate jacob claire ho i hope i'm
pronouncing that correctly and a belgian
developer
uh
boris
gorditz i hope i'm pronouncing that
correctly both founders are seemingly uh
young and based on their linkedin
profiles and the company has raised no
outside funding to date according to
techcrunch but according to the
techcrunch article yesterday quote
mimicking the appeal of fantasy sports
leagues and giving users a way to
compete with friends by betting on
startups they think will be successful
so the way it worked was users could bid
on nft shares of hundreds of different
startups at auction and compete to build
the best performing fake portfolio just
like in stock trading or fantasy you can
do this uh the crazy thing about this
though which i thought was interesting
was
and i made this observation
you
as a non-accredited investor
cannot buy shares in a private company
here in the united states the sec has
accreditation laws accreditation laws
mean you have to make two or three
hundred thousand dollars a year or half
a million dollars in uh liquid net worth
outside of the cost of your home
in order to make the very scary
dangerous bet of betting on uber when it
was private or robin hood or you know
today stripes spacex like
you're too dumb
is essentially uh what they're saying to
you you're too dumb to buy spacex right
you see all the rockets go up your
friend has um
you know starlink and you played video
games on and you're amazed at how
awesome it was and
you know uh you used stripe for the last
seven years on your uh you know
ecommerce site but you're too dumb
because you don't have three hundred
thousand dollars a year in salary or
your parents didn't gift you a million
dollars in your trust fund
therefore you can't buy um private
company stock that's what the
accreditation laws here in the united
states say other countries don't have
these and here in the united states you
can buy nfts
which are
securities and in this case they
literally made them as shadow securities
so the great irony here is people are
buying nfts to gamble to watch them
appreciate in value we all know nobody's
buying these nfts because of the
you know inherent value of the jpeg of
the image or the 3d model because
before nfts existed people weren't
paying for them right like maybe people
would buy a logo but they weren't buying
jpegs right we would go on the internet
there'd be jpegs everywhere i mean there
were stock photos for commercial use
there were
logos you could have designed
and so what this has really got me
tilted a bit on is
you know the sec is allowing nfts to be
sold and traded
for fun and profit and the profit is the
majority of why people are doing this
let's be totally candid here if these
things were all worth a dollar or three
dollars and they didn't appreciate in
value
you know if they appreciated five or ten
percent a year would there be a mania
going on here absolutely not the mania
is caused because i don't know what the
floor price is for a drunken monkey or a
you know a crypto emo nerd
you know like
but it's hundreds of thousands of
dollars like it's ridiculous it's the
cost of an average home in the united
states it's you know four times five
times ten times the sa average salary in
the united states this has become
something wildly different in practice
now does that mean i think people
shouldn't be allowed to buy nfts no no
it's your money right be aware that it's
probably a rigged game there's probably
people painting the tape there's
probably people front running the market
as we saw an employee at openc was
buying nfts and then flipping them and
making suckers out of open seas
customers right an insider trading
basically front running of the market um
so if they caught one person you know
not
uh singling out open c um you can be
certain that there are collective groups
manipulating the market
but you can't buy private companies
really now somebody pointed out like oh
i'm just talking about my book here i
just want more people to invest in
startups so i do want more people to
invest in startups but not because i
profit from it
you know
99.999 of
startups that are invested in i'm not on
the cap table a surprise like
this is something i think would be good
for all americans and it's a freedom
issue for me um and it's about people
moving from one station in life maybe
they're poor they want to be middle
class maybe they're middle class they
want to be upper middle class upper
middle class they want to be rich
they're rich they want to be elite well
the rich people can already do this and
the upper middle class can already do it
but so why can't the middle class or
people who are just starting their
careers do it it makes no sense it's
silly it should be like a driver's
license it should be like a gun license
if you can take a driver's license or
you can get a gun license and take a
certification test
seems to me that more dangerous to own a
gun or drive a car down the highway than
it is to own private company stock i
think we could all agree on that right
or maybe you would rank those three
things in a certain order
i would put owning a gun no i put
driving a car owning a gun and then
probably
uh owning stock a distant third so
anyway quote the founders hope that the
game like nature of the platform will
discourage those companies from sending
out cease and desist letters because
they didn't get permission from the
startups listed in the marketplace
according to the article and this is um
the key issue there was another website
that
biology and some other people invested
in
that was using people's likenesses to
create a market in crypto and they would
take the top twitter handles and they
automatically put them in the
marketplace and let people start trading
on them bitcloud is the name of the
company uh this is called trading on
somebody's likeness you're stealing
somebody who's a celebrity's likeness
big clout should have been sued by that
i just think nobody really took the time
to do it you can't trade on other
people's likenesses and their images
that's illegal especially when they're
celebrities
so but you know listen i'm not going to
start a war over it but you know i was a
high profile person i would certainly
send a cease and desist take my image
off there because you're confusing the
public so when i saw on big cloud
you know naval elon whoever high profile
crypto people i assumed that they
had signed up and in fact there's no
indication they didn't um it's totally
not clear you see their image you see
their likeness so i think the big cloud
people are lying and deceiving people
and that's not right right and you're
doing that on top of crypto which has
its
own issues like how dare you put
somebody's image on your home page and
let people start trading in their stock
or showing interest it's really it's
gnarly um you got to make that super
clear you make a list these are people
who've signed up and you can say these
are people we would like to sign up so
put that on a separate page or put it on
a separate sync you know
a list when people do devious stuff like
that like big clout was doing all this
like smarmy devious
lying kind of stuff that tells you all
you need to know about those individuals
in my mind if they would lie about that
what else are they lying about in their
business how what other corners are they
cutting that's the way i look at the
world when i see people bending the
truth or being like that i wonder now
for this one if you said i want to make
a bet
on
uh companies and i want to make a
fantasy group of this you and you maybe
you didn't use their logos and you let
people put in the name of the companies
and you're not profiting from it that
would be different so once if it was a
non-commercial project that also is
different
big cloud stands to make hundreds of
millions billions of dollars building
their service that's their goal
uh this company was selling the nfts so
once you start
actually doing commerce that changes it
fair use is a test and so the fair use
doctrine here would apply if you were
not making money perhaps and not using
their logo and not confusing the public
those would all be part of the tests a
judge would put this through if it
actually went to court of course it
wouldn't go to court
listen right now linkedin is going to
give you a hundred dollar credit towards
your first ad campaign i want you to go
to linkedin.com
this week in startups and get that
hyundy right now now why would you use
linkedin marketing
high quality leads we all need leads
we're all running businesses here my
leads startup founders your leads might
be sas enterprise it might be cfos it
might be cmos it might be ctos who knows
everybody's got a different product but
everybody is on linkedin we all know
that because we all use linkedin every
single day so if you're planning a
launch a new campaign you know your
audience your team is excited and
everything is going according to plan
we've all been there except you have
that one thought in the back your head
how can i be sure that my acquisition
campaign will drive high impact leads
for my sales team well with linkedin ads
you don't need to guess because when you
advertise on linkedin your message
reaches people who are ready to engage
you linkedin equals business business
equals linkedin you know this it's very
simple so with 30 million companies
engaging and over 71 of professionals
using linkedin to inform their business
decisions
linkedin can help bring your growth to
the next level
don't wait to start achieving your brand
and lead gen goals get a 100 ad credit
towards your first linkedin campaign at
linkedin.com
this week in startups once again
linkedin.com slash this week in startups
for the hyundai no spaces no dashes and
terms and conditions applied because
they're giving you a handy